ちょ、もう一回言っていい？
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと…
確実にデブに近づいていっております我々二人…
どうする!?やばいべ！
ま：やばい。ホントにやばい。
太ったらもうどうするかって言うと
ご飯を少なくするか、運動するかの二択だと思っております。
でもやっぱ、食べたいじゃないすか。食べたいんで。
何かしらを腹に入れないとやっぱやる気もでないし、力も出ないんですけども
どうすれば、お腹一杯になってこう痩せれるのかと思った時に
これを見つけました！
たぶんコンビニとかではよく見ると思うんですけども
飲んでふくらむ小腹サポート
がまんできない空腹感に
これ凄いんすよ。
ここに書いてあることがすべてを表しております。
「おなかでふくらむ」コバラサポート。
で、でこれを飲むとお腹自体が膨らむらしいです。
いや、ホントお腹が膨らむって事は
これを飲むだけでなんかお腹がこう、膨らんで
それだけで、空腹感を満たされるという、画期的なドリンクらしいです。
で、カロリーも…
29Kcal(キロカロリー)。
脂質０
糖質5.9g
だいぶ抑えてありますね
これ、ワンチャン、俺…
飲んでお腹が膨らむんだったらこれ
たくさん飲めば、ひょっとしたらお腹が凄え膨らむんじゃないかと思って。
逆にもうなんか1週間分ぐらい空腹感満たしちゃおうと思って…
今日はちょっとこのコバラサポートの限界まで(？)今から飲んでみて
お腹が実際に膨らむのかどうかってのを検証して行きたいと思います
実際わかんないでしょ、だってあの、書いてあるわけよ。
「おなかでふくらむ」って
実際にお腹が膨らむかどうかを見ていきましょう
ま：はい
痩せるぞ!!
まず、飲む前のお腹のウエストをはかっておきます。
僕のウエスト大体見た感じ23.5(cm)ぐらいですね。
ウエストが23.5(cm)で、あの、今寝起きで何にも食べてません。
ここから、如何にお腹を膨らませるか、やっていきましょう。
果たして、僕のウエストはどれぐらい伸びるのでしょうか？
美味いんだよね
ま：…うん。
や待ってこ… やばい
ね、まだ余裕だよ…ここからよ？
膨らんでほしいね、実際でも。
で、ワンタン膨らみすぎたら
爆発するか、四週間位もう食わなくてよくなるか。
すっ凄いよ…ホラ…
ま：てか多分これ、朝一発目にやるもんでもないよね。
間違いねえ…
ま：やばいねぇ(暗黒微笑)
すっげえ溜まるんだけど…
あれ？なんか…
え、まって膨らんでね？あるぜコレ。
ま：「イッイクゥ～」みたいに言わないで
でも凄いよ、今…
4本合わせて今…
…やばい…
う～やばい本当にもう
ま：出すのはNGで。
分かった…
苦しい！
いぃやコレ…ちっと、先ず1Lは行っときましょう。
いや～、これやばいよ。上腹がここ凄い…
ま：ホントだー
ﾎﾗﾎﾗﾎﾗ
ま：やばくない？
結構凄いよ。ほら、結構張ってない？
ま：うん
死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ
うん！
ちょっと待って…
ま：はぇ～本当に…
もう無理…
もう無理もうもう本当のデブ男…
これ以上摂ったら爆発するかもよ。
吐くというより、溜まって吐けない感じ。
ま：あ～～～
お腹に強制的に膜張って溜まっていく感じ。
ちょっと、じゃ測ってみましょ。
飲む前が23.5センチだったので
飲んだ後のウエストはどれ位になってるのか測っていきましょう。
結果！
…変わってない…
オーーパビニーアーーーー
アノマローーーーカリス
ド―ドーー
ステゴサーーーウルス
はじめしゃーちょーおーーーー
んちゃ！んちゃ！んちゃ！んちゃ！
ZE☆TSU☆ME☆TSU！！！！